Responsive design, I know.
It's fun to resize your web browser
and see which sites resize gracefully,
and which sites remain defiantly large
with gross horizontal scroll bars.
But responsive design
is not just for the web.
Today, the lines between phones
and tablet's are disappearing.
So it's important to think about how
your UI will scale
in our multiscreen world.
Don't be overwhelmed.
Just like designing responsive layouts
for the web, build your layouts
to be reasonably flexible
or within a common device size.
Then you can set break points,
providing alternative layouts
for those various sizes.
Think about it this way,
small phone, large phone,
medium tablet, and large tablet.